l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fa vj oggi sono con un mio
amico da the co proveremo a fare ma
fammi parlare
se questo è il mio video e parlo quando
cazzo voglio ai caprino e faremo una
partita playground come cazzi chiamato
giochi playout non bat donna titolo che
non ha senso di esistere se premi
effettiva per sganciare dal mio treno
premiamo poi 123
ecco chi è che ti vai vai vai giù non so
come sia prepara che fonde ok allora ti
vedo mai paracadute paracadute perché
muori e soprano pietro per torino aperto
io sono in mezzo alla foresta però vado
in un periodo diverso ma è un attimo che
quanto piano scendendo allora scende ma
perché sei un nero giunto io sono una
tipa allora bisogna andare a fare
attenzione che ci troveremo una macchina
qua ci sono anche le navi neanche le
navi sono anche le navi le navi fatidico
l'antico shepherd e la bardot occhio
dietro ma se dovessero morto non solo
molto sto sanguinando tantissimi
leinster dai era resta la grande di
brutto la mia mi ha ucciso
bello questo gioco bello se non
prendiamo le armi invece di saltare come
degli ultimi 6 belardi allenamento ore 6
eccoti eccoti qua sempre col casco il
musical allora proprio chi stava bene
che chernobyl di sotto non parliamo il
non andiamo al 15 buttiamo suppo cinti
che guarda dove andiamo insieme insieme
ci sono tipici sono tifosi e non so come
si fa le armi neanche io devo scendere
ancora segni bastarda e vabbè cazzo sei
spider man army armi armi aiuto aspetta
aspetta non ci sono armi e che se lo
faccio col berretto li picchio occhio
ma sarei stronzo occhio è poi la vediamo
quindi come vedi con me vabbè ma c'erano
altre armi tu sei un dio che è successo
non so ma sei scema c'è dei tic tramis
tola zaino ed i pantaloni grazie a dio
allora io non so come quanto danno si fa
in questo gioco attenzione vedo gente si
chiami tu anche noi e vi sta sparando
perfetto per adesso non è contro un muro
occhio ma non sai intorno al caso tuo no
no no non uscire non uscire e aspetta
che sta arrivando alla ve esce al mio
via
ok che accadeva da milvio però vrsc esci
c'è un oceano esce a mazzarà s maturavo
bravo gioco di squadra così si gioca
occhio che spara l'occhio che sparato
non so che che spara procchio via di qua
via via via colli via ricordi via via
via di como non capisco più vivo via col
risveglio guarda guarda qui sinistra c'è
una zona sicura alla mappa
no no no no la parola lombarda non ha
indicato che tu sei scemo venite con
tardavano dormine mente volevi andare tu
eri già ieri
porca vacca tu sei tutto scemo volevo
andare volevo andare a controllare
deferite a quest'ora tu eri carbonella
sei proprio triste e poi c'è un tipo c'è
un tipo farmi superficie tipo quanti
poco a doverlo è andato più avanti non
so occhio entra entra dentro tranquillo
ciao tipo uscito di qua
ammazzano almeno ammazzalo come tipi non
sono tipi sono divertiti qui niente però
siamo morti in the air che dai abbiamo
già fatto più chili in questo gioco che
in tutta la vita in h 10 ti senti casa
che parla così il super insulto le nega
nega suor signfica ha detto [ __ ] aveva
sentito tutti e torino preso furti o
madre spiega sul tablet ma tu madre
sciolta poca you can't buy back
ecco anche lei tra i 21
vai io sono qua che penso lo penso non
entra dentro dai ok dentro veloci troppo
dei colpi e una falce alla band è meglio
se c'è una pistola male di tackle aqua 1
mp o addirittura se sì ma dobbiamo
invece
sì ma devi toglierti l'ultimo sinistra
bravi bravi bravi ho trovato un back per
un deficiente ma che problemi al
cervello ai cosa fa ammette gillard
maltrattato un po ma da un micro usi di
sopra di hall armi a caso lì ho trovato
una macchina fotografica nomi faenza
foto alla posti poi ti metto il primo
aspetto aspetta sei completamente come
richard tipo occhio ha detto acceso 21
morto non sono a terra su un solo morto
uno reciso non ha ucciso una dietro è
capito la parola dietro posso fare spesi
quest'estate aspetta che sto concentrato
a destra e destra ed è aquilano vedo
zitto mi fai concentrare grazie cruz e
allora prova a fare una roba che non so
quanto funziona ma ci prova ma mai
filato perché ciò tutta la vista orba ma
non vedo sola persona cieca sei scarso
ma scarso ci sono anche uno era buona
l'idea di prendere il pompa però se
cifra investi maledizione c'è una
macchina qui il primo a chi mi basta non
ci sono mezzi in questo gioco non è vero
ci sono né visto uno ma sto madonna se
parte tipica una testata fortina in un
party tutta ruggine questa guida è una
serie di temi che veramente si piglia al
tetto non solo a guardarlo sua cameretta
mica io la prima cosa che fa centrali
mica se parte ti investo merda non parla
quarata andata solo bene
ma i tua madre ti picchiava da piccolo
ma non capisco questa è una segheria la
conosci bene ammazzati elmo vestiti sono
una persona di con dignità adesso siamo
nella zona sicura non siamo nella zona
sicura mai nella vita via e dobbiamo
correre nella zona sicura ma non riesco
penn dell'arno e lega un cazzo vai
ho trovato una madonna come sono coatto
ma dalla via via via via ecco il tasto
destro
riti neo e devo provare le armi non so
come sparano se la gittata non so niente
che sia un bel salto da qui penso che se
non lo fai tu io non lo faccio poi ci
possiamo farlo pian piano quindi qua ma
arriva il gala e la cosa esatto la loren
o sono bloccato un posto più scendere
nel salire non poter scendere del solito
deficiente l'ora cioè vorrei sopprimerci
lotion parlo io d'armi dami queste
brezza di ammazzarti fico poi voglio
voglio godermelo beh prova ci amassimo
morita 6
provaci velocemente che sta arrivando
gas grazie a casa ed istigare le persone
sui cibi non sono morto veramente non
sono un cazzo che culo come non sei
morto non ci posso credere o 30 18
capito no cretino
sì un critico a tanto che il 68 non sono
morto pietro al bar mi è però se la
vedrà con un ritardo di 48 o tipo 1 di
vita e ho ricordi sta arrivando il gas
cornice al codice un bike assassins che
allora no no no no dai
scherzavo prima aia tanto cianchi di
scusa chi discute da questa scusa
andiamo a curarci in casa cos'è quella
casa quella mano a casa dei puffi parte
io delle armi che deve lasciare
necessario vado a 99 sport a quella
aperta e non c'è niente qui sopra a mio
curate per un secondo gli annunci ai ha
visto il colpendo vista a e sono morti
insomma stavo guardando le cose per
quando vado alimentare io muoio che
cazzo sei bravo avevo visto chiasso lo
ammazzi tan tan tan atalanta amiche cosa
che stai facendo questa cosa quindi
occhio abbiamo fatto benissimo dubbi ce
n'erano due la random sicuro porca eva
avere ragazzi questo herakleia non ce la
farò mai nominare il suo gioco
impossibile finché non ti ammazzano un
bel gioco poi è una merda se dovessi
siete che ci vediamo ha proseguito e da
ragazzi
[Musica]